c'est un petit port de pêche pittoresque
sur le bord de la mer egée une
destination touristique très populaire
en turquie
mais depuis quelques mois la pêche et le
tourisme ont été supplantés asos est
devenue une plaque tournante du trafic
de migrants une activité illicite qui
s'exerce ici en plein jour au vu et au
su de tous les passeurs vont et viennent
dans le port sans être inquiété les
gendarmes passent le plus clair de leur
temps au café corruption ou intimidation
le résultat est le même
l'inaction à quelques encablures
l'activité est pourtant incessants on
est en train d'assister à deux départs
de bateaux climatique c'est vraiment
continuer ici sur la côte
depuis ce matin on en a déjà vu neuf et
chacun de ces bateaux pneumatiques
vraiment chargé bien au delà du
raisonnable
l'objectif est clair maximiser les
profits les passeurs se contente de
faire monter les migrants et de lancer
sommairement des embarcations dans la
bonne direction
il saute ensuite à l'eau pour gagner la
rive les passagers sans expérience sont
alors laissés à eux mêmes
poussif le moteur de 15 chevaux peine à
faire avancer zodiac puis s'arrête
l'embarcation instable prend l'eau les
passagers qui allaient bien vois tu vois
je vois tu trembles m 2 av
heureusement pour eux la rive est encore
proche il est encore possible de faire
demi tour
lui n'a pas eu la même chance
le pneumatique à bord duquel ils
prenaient place a sombré au milieu de la
traversée et reading
j'ai tout perdu mon sac mon argent mon
téléphone mais mes papiers de l'onu du
seigneur ne roule aussi un désastre
prévisible
soixante personnes prenaient place à
bord du bateau embarqué à la pointe du
fusil
ahmad n'a eu la vie sauve que grâce à
l'intervention d'un pêcheur qui l'a
secouru lui et les membres de sa famille
un drame qui se répète ici
quotidiennement chaque fois qu'il prend
la mer le capitaine hassan comme il se
fait appeler s'attend à devoir sauver
des migrants il en a déjà secouru 24 en
deux jours à la tragédie
une tragédie humaine dit-il des enfants
des bébés qui prennent la mer sans
savoir nager
il tombe dans l'eau il se nourrit vu le
mur d'eau hassan se sentent impuissants
toute la ville dit il vit dans la peur
sous la menace constante des passeurs un
réseau très bien organisés selon lui à
terre nous rencontrons un de ces
passeurs un de ces hommes qui font
monter les migrants à bord de bateaux le
pistolet à la main il se fait appeler
alibaba originaires d'afghanistan
c'est lui qui s'occupe des groupes venus
de ce pays comprend que mais les grands
patrons selon lui sont des kurdes en
échange de son travail
il affirme que ses chefs ont promis
d'envoyer gratuitement grèce puis en
allemagne
chaque bateau qui arrive en grèce
rapporte aux pacers autour de 100 mille
dollars
un trafic très lucratif assez pour
acheter le silence des uns et l'inaction
des autres voilà peut-être ce qui
explique pourquoi les gendarmes et si
détourne souvent les yeux et les
garde-côtes passe souvent leur chemin
ici jean françois bélanger radio canada
asos en turquie